[تصفيق]
يحملون زميلهم داخل عش ويركضون به في سباق
فريد من نوعه مهرجان الفكاهي يقاوم سنويا
في مدينه
كولورادو الامريكيه وقصه غريبه وراء هذه
الفعاليه السنويه انه سباق النعوش في
نادرلان المهرجان تاسس عام 2002 ويبدا في
عطله نهايه الاسبوع الثاني من شهر مارس
تزامنا مع انتهاء الشتاء وذوبان الثلوج
وبدايه فصل الربيع على مدار ثلاثه ايام
تتسابق هذه الفرق المتنافسه عبر مسارات
واعره تتخللها حواجز وعطبات كالوحل
والمياه البارده وغيرها
[موسيقى]
كل فريق مكون من سته افراد وشخص سابع
يستلقي في نعش يحملونه ويركضون به باقصى
سرعتهم نحو خط النهايه ويتضمن المهرجان
واحتفالات ورطاسات وفعاليات اخرى جميعها
تتمحور حول قصه الرجل الميت المتجمد قصه
المهرجان بدات احداثها في النرويج عام
1989 حين توفي شخص يدعى
وقام حفيده بنقل جثمانه الى امريكا وهناك
تم تجميده ووضعه في النيتروجين السائل
لاربع سنوات تقريبا لكن بعد ذلك تجاوز
الحفيد فتره اقامته داخل الولايات المتحده
وتم ترحيله الى النرويج فتولت والدته مهمه
حفظ الجثمان المجمد ثم تعاقب عده اشخاص
على المهمه بعد سماح السلطات لهم بذلك الى
ان وصلت الى براد هام الذي لا يزال يشرف
على حفظ جثمان الجد مجمدا الى يومنا هذا
في عام 2002 قامت بلده نيبرلاند الموجود
فيها جثمان الجد بتسميه مهرجانها الربيعي
السنوي بمهرجان الرجل الميت المجمد تكريما
لقصه الجد بريدو وحفيده
[تصفيق]
في المهرجان هناك رقصه تسمى كره جد زرقاء
اضافه الى تنظيم جوله في المكان الموجود
فيه جثمان جدي المجمد مع عرض افلام
وثائقيه لقصته ومع استمراريه شعبيه
المهرجان يبقى السؤال قائما حول مصير
الرجل المتجمد منذ 34 عاما والى متى سيبقى
جثنانه مجمدا هناك في كولورادو